[Music]
like coming out of got Gucci
unrecognised that stripe that looks nice
it's like nineties I love that about
there yes
rick has songs about sunglasses he has
you of your own sunglass collection
right I do I have I collect my own yes I
love it okay so he's never seen without
sunglasses which I love basically he's
known for his sunglasses oh so what's
with the sunglasses it could go back to
me as a youngster when I was a youngster
in elementary school a lot of my friends
used to pick on me because of the length
of my eyelashes wait are they like
really long wasted short these short
stubby little like and then pregnancy
ruined it even more it's like I
understand afterward lashes these have
nothing on me is mine and those are just
natural and you're hiding it I'm upset
with you Rick Ross and as a youngster I
hate it oh oh really I do
they're so beautiful but I do like the
shades too it's rock and roll I'd get
into it I might be fun to try on like a
few iconic frames see how they look on
you are you cool with that I'm with it
alright alright come on a bitter elf
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it's great you're gonna go with these
first these these are like they kind of
look like you to like Bono
a little bono esque so let's try these
make some noise Bono
exact
[Applause]
okay okay
well this one this is a I think Oprah
has been rocking a bold look like these
this is so I mean if it's good for Oprah
it's good for all of us right this is
probably you gotten so glasses you look
a perfect shape head I'm not kidding I
have to go for a specific styler it's
like nope okay we're going to go for
these obviously these are a little Elton
John make some noise for Elton John
[Applause]
cuz I'm just saying the bedazzle is nice
I may go with these let's seriously
let's talk about your book cause you
have a memoir out it's called hurricanes
right okay just so what what's it about
it's really just talking about my rise
you know my roster where I am today as
an artist you know just letting you know
that we all love the sun shining but you
will deal with hurricanes in life and
just you got to deal with them you got
to deal with them you move forward you
know I'm coming into album number 10 you
have to challenge yourself creative wise
and I wanted to bring something else to
the game in a different perspective so
me telling everyone just my straight for
me my voice and I felt it'll blow a lot
of people Minds yeah and I wanted it to
come out with the album that album went
number one so yeah it's just a lot of
my fans just to get like inside your
heart and head that's why I like to be a
songwriter i like singing songs that I
didn't write but I also love to write
because it gives people the opportunity
to kind of see who you are
so I actually heard that you were
recently nominated for Grammy right I am
go roses featuring Drake one time for
Drake yeah what makes a moment even that
much more special as the record was
actually conceived from a conversation
me and Drake had over Nipsey Hussle you
know recipes to Nipsey Hussle it was a
conversation that we had and we was just
speaking about you have to a lot of
times let's celebrate a person's energy
why they're still here to accept it you
know and that's what it was about you
are you the clock is tickin the clock is
ticking it you know it's it feels like
you never finished when you have for a
little beautiful children oh me too as
well it's like it's never I still think
I'm done and then I'm like wait did I
did I even it out cuz do they count they
count the gifts like they got more than
me and not only that it's you know 4:00
in the morning it's like Amazon is just
knocking at you oh my gosh
well are you stressed about the holidays
you get stressed about it both of you
I try not to you don't get stressed you
get stressed I'm totally stressed I get
stressed I think the mom is getting
super stressed we feel like we're the
ones that people are gonna look at would
be like it wasn't great
yeah and we got a cook too yeah
beautiful I'm sous-chef my sister does
that yeah my sister's like solid in a
kitchen I am solid eating in a kitchen I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this